BUT FIRST, FAUX LIBERAL OUTRAGE
IN THE DISCRETION            DES
IN THE DISCRETION            DER
IN THE DISCRETION            DEC
IN THE DISCRETION            DEI
IN THE DISCRETION            DEN
IN THE DISCRETION            DEO
IN THE DISCRETION            DEF
IN THE DISCRETION            DET
IN THE DISCRETION            DEE
IN THE DISCRETION            DER
IN THE DISCRETION            DEL
IN THE DISCRETION            DEE
OF LAW.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
EVERY COUNTRY HAS AN OBLIGATION
TO PROTECT ITS BORDERS AND ITS
CITIZENS, PARTICULARLY ONE AS
EXTENSIVE AND GENEROUS AS THE
UNITED STATES.
FOR TOO LONG, IMMIGRATION LAW
WAS IGNORED FRANKLY AND
BASICALLY UNENFORCED.
OBAMA TRIED TO KIND OF ENFORCE
IT IN AN AD HOC FASHION BUT THE
POLICIES WHICH I WILL GET TO A
NEW MOMENT ONLY ENDED UP
EXACERBATING OUR PROBLEMS
AT THE BORDER.
TODAY WE HAVE A FULL ON CRISIS.
160% INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE ILLEGALLY ENTERING THE
UNITED STATES FROM JUST LAST
YEAR.
WHILE, THE PRESIDENT IS
RESPONDING WITH A ZERO TOLERANCE
MESSAGE WHICH SHE REITERATED
TODAY.
>> THE UNITED STATES WILL NOT BE
A MIGRANT CAMP, AND IT WILL NOT
BE A REFUGEE HOLDING FACILITY.
IT WON'T BE.
YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
EUROPE.
OTHER PLACES.
WE CAN'T ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN TO
THE UNITED STATES, NOT ON MY
WATCH.
>> Laura: NOW, THE PRESIDENT
IS NOT DOING -- NOW DOING WHAT E
SHOULD'VE BEEN DOING ALL
ALONG, PROSECUTING ALL BORDER
CRUSHERS.
IF YOUR ENTER THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY YOU ARE BREAKING THE
LAW FOR THE UNITED STATES IS NOT
AN OPEN RAPACIOUS AND CENTER
WERE ANY INDIGENOUS PERSON IN
THE WORLD ASSUMES WE WILL TAKE
CARE OF THEM AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
THERE IS A PROCESS AND IT HAS TO
BE RESPECTED.
HOMELAND SECURITY CHIEF KIRSTJEN
NIELSEN SAID THIS TODAY.
>> WE ARE A COMPASSIONATE
COUNTRY THAT HAS TAKEN IN
MILLIONS OF REFUGEES.
SINCE 1975, THE UNITED STATES
HAS WELCOMED MORE THAN 3 MILLION
REFUGEES FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD
REFUGEES FROM ALL OVER THE WORL
WORLD.
AND EACH YEAR, TYPICALLY ADMITS
NEARLY TWO-THIRDS OF THE WORLD
SETTLED REFUGEES.
THAT IS MORE THAN ALL OTHER
COUNTRIES COMBINED.
WE WILL NOT APOLOGIZE FOR THE
JOB WE DO OR FOR THE JOB
LAW ENFORCEMENT DOES FOR DOING
THE JOB THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
EXPECT US TO DO.
ILLEGAL ACTIONS HAVE AND MUST
HAVE CONS WITH THIS.
NO MORE FREE PASSES.
NO MORE GET-OUT-OF-JAIL-FREE
CARDS.
>> Laura: CONSISTENT WITH
AMERICAN LAW WHEN THE PARTIES
ARRESTED, YOUR CHILDREN ARE
EITHER SENT TO RELATIVES OR THEY
BECOME WARDS OF THE STATE.
SINCE MORE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
ARE RUSHING THE PARTICLE OR MORE
KIDS ARE BEING SEPARATED FROM
THEIR PARENTS.
AND TEMPORARILY HOUSED IN WHAT
ARE ESSENTIALLY SUMMER CAMPS OR,
AS THE "SAN DIEGO UNION TRIBUNE"
ASCRIBED THEM TO MAKE HIM AS
LOOKING LIKE BASICALLY BOARDING
SCHOOLS.
HAVING LOST THE ARGUMENT AND
FRANKLY THE LAST ELECTION,
LIBERALS HAVE SEIZED ON THE
SEPARATED CHILDREN AND TURNED
THE ENTIRE IMAGE INTO A
POLITICAL WEAPON.
ATTEMPTING TO EMOTIONALLY
MUTILATE THE PUBLIC'S PERCEPTION
OF IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT.
>> I HAVE READ THAT YOU SAID
THAT THE SEPARATION, AND YOUR
WORDS TO ME SAID IT'S NOTHING
LESS THAN GOVERNMENT SANCTIONED
CHILD ABUSE.
DO YOU REALLY THINK THIS AMOUNTS
TO CHILD ABUSE?
>> THIS DOES AMOUNT TO CHILD
ABUSE.
ALL I CAN SAY AFTER TALKING TO
THE PEOPLE, WATCHING THE PEOPLE,
LISTENING TO THE PEOPLE THAT THE
STATUE OF LIBERTY I THINK IT'S
WEEPING RIGHT NOW.
>> EFFECTIVELY ORPHANED
THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN FROM THEIR
PARENTS.
>> I AM HEARTBROKEN BY WHAT'S
HAPPENING, AND I WONDER WHAT
THIS MEANS ABOUT THE FABRIC OF
OUR COUNTRY.
>> NOW, WHY ARE ALL THEIR
HEARTS BREAKING IN UNISON NOW?
WHY NO TEARS FOR THE VICTIMS OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT CRIME LIKE THE
14-YEAR-OLD GIRL RAPED JUST LAST
MONTH.
OR DID THEIR HEARTBREAK WHEN
SOMEONE WAS LEFT TO DIE AT THE
SCENE OF A HIT-AND-RUN BY
21-YEAR-OLD MEXICAN NATIONAL?
HERE IS WHAT YOU ARE NOT
HEARING.
THE GOVERNMENT HAS VERY GOOD
REASON FOR SEPARATING THESE
CHILDREN FROM THEIR FAMILY
UNITS.
THE FIRST BEING THEY MAY NOT BE
THE CHILD'S FAMILY AT ALL.
CHILDREN HAVE BEEN KIDNAPPED,
TRAFFIC, AND USED BY INDIVIDUALS
WHO CAN MORE EASILY SLIP INTO
THE COUNTRY.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION'S CATCH
AND RELEASE POLICY ALLOW PEOPLE
WITH CHILDREN TO ENTER THE
UNITED STATES WITH ONLY A
PROMISE TO SHOW UP FOR A LATER
HEARING.
A LOT OF THEM DIDN'T SHOW UP OF
COURSE.
THE HUMAN TRAFFICKERS AND THE
DRUG CARTELS QUICKLY SEIZED ON
THE WEAKNESS AND EXPLOITED IT.
ROUTINELY TRAFFICKING PEOPLE
ACROSS THE BORDER USING CHILDREN
AT TIMES AS CAMOUFLAGE.
THEN WHEN OBAMA ANNOUNCED TO
DACA POLICY IN 2012, IT BECAME
YET ANOTHER LORD FOR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
THE NUMBER OF UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS FROM EL SALVADOR,
GUATEMALA, AND HONDURAS, SURGED
BETWEEN 2012 AND 2014.
CHECK THIS OUT.
BY MORE THAN 400%.
THE NUMBER OF UNACCOMPANIED
CHILDREN REFER TO THE OFFICE OF
REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT TRIPLED
BETWEEN 2012 AND 2017 FROM
13,625 TO 40,810, ACCORDING TO
THE GOVERNMENT STATISTICS.
FROM THESE IMMIGRANTS COME FRESH
RECRUITS FOR MS-13 AND OTHER
GANGS THAT TERRORIZED AMERICAN
CITIES FROM MARYLAND TO
CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE TALKED TO THE OFFICIALS.
WE HAVE TOLD THE STORIES.
IN JUNE OF 2014, EVEN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" HAD TO
ADMIT THAT THE UNACCOMPANIED
MINOR SURGE WAS "DRIVEN IN LARGE
PART BY THE PERCEPTION THAT THEY
WILL BE ALLOWED TO STAY UNDER
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION'S
IMMIGRATION POLICY."
ASTOUNDINGLY IN THE FISCAL YEAR
2014, THE BORDER PATROL
APPREHENDED 68,445 "FAMILY
UNITS."
FEEL, OF COURSE, WERE DEPORTED.
THROW IN SANCTUARY CITIES, A LAX
AMNESTY PROGRAM, AND IT'S A
WONDER MORE ILLEGALS HAVEN'T
COME.
SO THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
NOW TRYING TO PICK UP THE PIECES
OF THIS LAWLESS IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM AFTER DECADES OF
GOVERNMENTAL NEGLECT.
THEY ARE ALSO TRYING TO
RESPONSIBLY PROTECT CHILDREN IN
THE GOVERNMENT'S CARE.
HERE ARE THE CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER
WHICH THEY TEMPORARILY TAKEN TO
CUSTODY OF CHILDREN.
NUMBER ONE, WHEN DHS IS UNABLE
TO VERIFY THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN THE ADULT IN THE CHILD.
NUMBER TWO, WHEN DHS DETERMINES
THAT A CHILD MAY BE AT RISK WITH
THE PARENT OR THE LEGAL
GUARDIAN, AND THREE, WITH A
PARENT OR LEGAL GUARDIAN IS
REFERRED FOR CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION.
YOU ENTER INTO A NORMAL PORT OF
ENTRY RATHER THAN COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER ILLEGALLY AND THE
CHANCES ARE YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
BE SEPARATED FROM THEIR
FAMILIES.
BUT MOST OF THESE PEOPLE ARE
COMING STRAIGHT ACROSS THE
BORDER AS ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS,
THEN CLAIMING SOME TYPE OF
STATUS OR ASYLUM REQUEST.
THIS ALL GOES BACK TO A 1997
COURT RULING WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
BEFORE ON THE SHOW CALLED THE
FLORIDA SETTLEMENT WHICH FORBADE
THE GOVERNMENT FROM HOLDING
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN FROM
WITHIN 20 DAYS.
FOR THOSE TRAVELING WITH FAMILY
UNITS.
YOU HAVE A HEARING WITHIN 20
DAYS, THEY HAVE TO BE
RELEASED INTO THE COUNTRY.
LEST YOU CAN BE SWAYED BY THE
MEDIA REPORTS THAT THE CHILDREN
ARE HOUSED IN CONCENTRATION CAPS
OR CAGES, THE TRUTH IS THE U.S.
TAX PAPER IS SPENDING A LOT ON
THE CARE OF THESE CHILDREN.
NEARLY $35,000 PER YEAR PER
CHILD.
THEY HAVE A HIGHER STANDARD OF
LIVING WITHIN THE 13 MILLION
AMERICAN CHILDREN TODAY
CURRENTLY LIVING BELOW THE
POVERTY LINE.
IT'S ABOUT 24,000 PER HOUSEHOLD.
AS FOR THE CONDITIONS OF THE
CHILDREN ARE HOUSED IN, THEY
LIVE A LOT BETTER THAN SOME
INNER-CITY KIDS ARE SAY THE
11,472 HOMELESS VETERANS LIVING
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
>> ANYTHING WE'VE SEEN, THE
GOVERNMENT HAS PROVIDED.
IT DOESN'T FEEL LIKE WE ARE IN
THE UNITED STATES.
>> DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES INVITED US INSIDE
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO SHOW US
RELATIVELY SPEAKING HUG WITH THE
CONDITIONS ARE, I GUESS YOU
COULD SAY.
THERE ARE LICENSED PROFESSIONALS
AND THEY ARE TAKING CARE OF THE
CHILDREN.
THEY ARE NOT CAGES.
THEY ARE NOT FENCES.
>> Laura: IT'S JUST
RIDICULOUS.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THESE KIDS
SHOULD BE UNITED WITH HER
PARENTS, FOR SURE.
REUNITED WITH HER PARENTS.
BACK IN THEIR HOME COUNTRIES.
THEY SHOULD NOT BE BURDENS TO
THE UNITED STATES TAXPAYER OR
THROWN INTO A SYSTEM OF FOSTER
CARE BY PARENTS WHO THINK COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER WITH CHILDREN
WOULD ASSURE THEM EVENTUALLY
LEGALIZED STATUS.
THE PRESIDENT WANTS THE
SEPARATION TO END AS WELL.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS SAID THIS
LAWLESSNESS CANNOT CONTINUE.
WE DO NOT WANT TO SEPARATE
PARENTS FROM THEIR CHILDREN.
YOU CAN BE SURE OF THAT.
IF WE BUILD A WALL, WE PASSED
SOME LEGISLATION, WE CLOSE SOME
LOOPHOLES, WE WON'T FACE THESE
TERRIBLE CHOICES.
>> Laura: RATHER THAN TRY TO
SCORE POLITICAL POINTS,
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS LIKE
SESSIONS IS INDICATED, SHOULD
COME TOGETHER.
THEY SHOULD DO WHAT'S BEST FOR
THE COUNTRY, FOR THE AMERICAN
CITIZEN AND THE AMERICAN WORKERS
AND THESE IMMIGRANT CHILDREN.
THE LAW SHOULD BE CHANGED SO
THAT THE BORDER PATROL CAN TURN
AWAY INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILY
UNITS AT THE BORDER IF NECESSARY
UNITS AT THE BORDER IF NECESSAR
NECESSARY.
TODAY, ONLY MEXICANS WHO CROSS
THE BORDER ILLEGALLY CAN BE
TURNED BACK.
THAT'S ABSURD.
OUR BORDER PATROL DOESN'T EXIST
AS A WAVE AND FACILITATOR FOR
ANY GROUP OF SUPPOSED FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO MOUTHED THE SCRIPT
GIVEN TO THEM BY LAWYERS,
NONGOVERNMENTAL INSTITUTIONS OR
OTHER PEOPLE IN THEIR HOME
COUNTRIES THAT THEY MOUTH FOR
ASYLUM.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE FOOTING
A REALLY BIG BILL FOR WHAT IS
TANTAMOUNT TO A SLOW ROLLING
INVASION OF THE UNITED STATES.
AND WE CAN NO LONGER PERMIT
CENTRAL AMERICAN COUNTRIES TO
EXPORT THEIR PROPERTY AND THEIR
DESPERATION TO OUR NATION.
OUR OWN CHILDREN, BLACK, WHITE,
ASIAN, LATINO NEED HELP TOO.
IN DETROIT, HERE IN L.A., IN
HARTFORD, MIAMI, CHICAGO.
SO WHY DON'T THE BUSHES AND
OBAMA'S AND THESE LEFT-WING
REPORTERS EMOTING TODAY THE
WHITE HOUSE AND ALL THE
PRO-AMNESTY DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS, WHY DON'T THEY EVER
WRITE OFF BEDS OR CRY FOR THOSE
KIDS?
YOU KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE THEY THINK THIS OVER THE
AND THE MISREPRESENTED WILL OF